on camera we're not doing an interview
why we'll explain why how do you feel
about that influence that you have you
better be careful we're coming for your
children they buddy about Maring Nation
yes I'm going to do you're going to
resign I'm going I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pgan un sensor Palestinian
doctor iseline abues has lost more than
22 members of his family to war with
Israel somehow he still believes
passionately in peace he joins me
live calls for CE firing Gaza grow ever
louder should Israel hold his fire would
that be a gift for Hamas Jen Yuga and
Rabbi shmuli go head to
head plus protesters across the world
have been tearing down posters of
Israelis captured and kidnapped by
terrorists this m has called on camera
doing it I ask him
[Music]
why live from the news building in
London this is Pier Morgan uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Pi Morgan uncensor the job of the Home
Secretary is to keep our country safe
soel braan is doing the exact opposite
her Rec disregard for the responsibility
of the office she holds a very high
office is now actively putting people in
danger quite frankly she's become a
disgrace to her government and her
country today bran accused London's met
police of playing favorites with Pro
Palestine protesters even going as far
as to claim the senior officers are
deliberately allowing them to break the
law she slurs the protesters as mobs and
no matter where you stand on the
Palestine March planned for Armes day
the Home Secretary should be calling for
calm and then the police get on with
their jobs instead she's pouring fuel on
the Flames of a tense situation that's
already in grave danger of blowing up
this was the reaction of former met
Chief superintendent Dal Babu rightwing
groups are going to turn up who have
been emboldened by what the Home
Secretary says some of the things that
so bra is saying as a as a a brown woman
would would not be tolerated if it were
said by a white man a white woman you
know some of the things she said about
Pakistani men some of the things she's
saying about hate marches you know I'm
I'm just flabbergasted well he's right
as officers prepared to keep the peace
at one of the most inflammatory public
demonstrations in years she's
effectively told the public they can't
trust the police she compared the
Palestine supporters to Protestants in
Northern Ireland equating her own
unionist supporters with terrorist
sympathizers she called an anti-war
protest a hate march to rile the public
now she's given the green light to
Vigilantes all this in the same week she
outrageously said that being homeless is
a lifestyle choice and she wants to ban
homeless people from sleeping in tents
for all our sakes braan needs time off a
lot of time off Downing Street says it
had no forewarning of her comments which
makes prime minister Rishi sunak look
well weak it's no surprise that labor is
now demanding she's fired this isn't the
way in which a Home Secretary should
behave he must know in himself that the
role of responsible governments is to
reduce tension and to support the police
in difficult decisions that they have to
make he's got a A Home Secretary who's
who's out of control and he is too weak
to do anything about it well like many
people in this country I feel
uncomfortable about the armist day
armist day March but I fundamentally
believe in the right to peaceful protest
and to freedom of speech the minority of
people who turn up to incite violence or
glorify terrorist should be dealt with
by the police there are laws that
prohibit this the police already know
that now the Home Secretary is sent into
a volatile situation that she's made
even more dangerous braan has been been
fired from his job once before over a
massive security breach Richie sunak
shouldn't have rehired her I said that
at the time now he needs to fire again
and this time for
good well my first guest tonight has
lost an unbelievably large number of
relatives to war in Gaza in 2009 tragedy
struck Dr iseline abues when an Israeli
tank shelled his home claiming the lives
of his three daughters and a niece
but the current conflict has also taken
the lives of many more of his relatives
and Dr abues a trailblazing figure made
history of the First Palestinian doctor
to serve in an Israeli hospital he's a
passionate advocate for peace and
Reconciliation between Israelis and
Palestinians a mission that he
encapsulated in his Memoir entitled I
shall not hate a Gaza doctor's Journey
on the path to peace and human dignity
and I'm I feel honored actually to say
that Dr iseline abues joins me now
doctor thank you for coming here today
thank you thank you so much I I greatly
appreciate it I know we were just
talking before we came on air you were
raised in the jabali refugee camp I was
born raised and lived and my home is
still in jabalia Camp and a lot of your
relatives have already been killed since
October the 7th there yes uh in these
air strikes but also you've told me that
right now there are ongoing attacks yes
they are there in ja camp living staying
there they are alive
now I don't know after we finish if
there will be alive to talk to them or
not but it's important P I want to tell
you let us talk a man to a man do you
have children yes so a father to a
father a human to human you
know once the app fell down we discover
the
gravity so let us
today discover the humanity and the
truth truth because the truth is
important based on evidence Jesus said
seek the truth and the truth sets you
free and I hope all to be free today
from this meeting and to be human and to
behave as a human and to Advocate only
and just only for a Humanity how many
members of your family have been lost
since October the 7th about the
25 October 7th when i w watched it I
found that my sister's house where my
brothers and nieces were there and this
is all the members of the family who
were killed these are all your members
of your family of the family on the
seventh they became biles their
bodies this is my
niece who was killed this is her
body this my
niece who was in engineer
graduated she found she was found under
the
rubel this is my nie is a medical doctor
she was supposed to start her
speciality this my cousin this is my
nephew who is a
physiotherapist and he was
killed this is my niece's
daughter and that's what we want to see
these people they have
names they have faces and that's what is
needed this is my daughter
bisan who was killed 16th of January
2009 who said to meet violence with
violence doesn't solve any problem there
is an alternative way it's not by action
and reaction it's by being a human and
behaving and thinking of others this is
May and aah even my niece she named her
daughter a after my daughter a was
killed
also these daughters I raised them to be
human to be advocate for human I send
them to be
scams and she said to me with Israelis
with the Israelis and she said to me I
found how similar are we we are similar
but we need to be equal we need to be
free we need to appreciate the dignity
the freedom
of all does the life I want to ask you
does the life of the Palestinians matter
as equal to the Israelis or not yes does
the freedom of the Palestinians matter
as the freedom of the Israel is yes and
that's what always I advocated for I
walked at the hospital when I deliver a
baby the newborn baby The Cry of the
newborn baby is the Cry of Hope Cry of
life
but now we are crying blood our tears
are
blood the children that I help to
deliver they are free all of them are
free why not to run a normal free life
medicine for me is a human equalizer
stabilizer socializer and harmonizer so
we need to live a free with dignity with
equality in this world and that's the
peace I fully Advocate it because once
we have these means peace will be a
consequence violence that we talk about
violence what is violence violence when
we violate someone's dignity life and
the human rights so it's
time and even October 7th approved
because we tried it many times military
means and Wars It's a futile it's a
waste of time and
lives increases Bloodshed animosity
hatred violence pain suffering and most
important is the extremism the only way
is to set and I am sure this can't be
solved with the military means it's only
by political and diplomatic means
acknowledging the rights of all to live
side by side as equal
and that's the only way without leaving
anyone
behind you talked earlier about growing
up in the jabali refugee camp which was
struck of course by air strikes
devastatingly killing member members of
your fames you've just recounted so
powerfully what was life like when you
were there as a young person My Life as
a Palestinian refugee because I was born
as a refugee my parents were
refugees my grandparents were refugees
they were expelled from their Homeland
to be thrown as a refugee and being a
refugee what do we mean by a
refugee you are deprived of your dignity
you become moving in this world naked
exposed but thanks to our parents that
they lost everything but they realize
the hope is in their children we have to
be educated and Palestinian people they
invest everything in the education of
their
children they cut from their food that
now in Gaza STP with the collective
punishment they are deprived of a bread
of water of health of gas of a fuel how
the
world can watch it and not to take
action how can you tolerate to see your
son hungry he needs milk what are you
going to do when I see a bleeding
patient I rush to stop the bleeding when
I see a woman who is in labor pain I
rush to help her without discrimination
or to say to her why are you screaming
why are you crying and that's what we
need so as a
child I
was I suffered of romatic fever admitted
to the hospital I wanted to be a medical
doctor in order to rescue my family from
the misery of life and that's we as
Palestinians we don't believe in the
impossible thing we have hope in our
children I succeeded to get a
scholarship to study medicine in Cairo
everything in life I planned I succeeded
from jabalia Camp to K University to
London to Italy to Belgium to Harvard
University even when I went to Harvard
the only thing which was
standing with me was Palestine flag to
be raised I am Palestinian and the proud
Palestinian
and that's what I want the world to hear
from the Palestinians Palestinians are
people like others with hopes with the
plans with the dreams they love life and
they care about others and that's what
we want the world to hear from us not to
hear about us the only impossible thing
I believe in is to return my daughters
back to life it was 2008 I think when
you lost your wife to cancer and that
was a crushing blow and you were left to
bring up your eight children on your own
yes and then within a year devastatingly
an Israeli tank during that war at the
time that was raging at the time with
Gaza an Israeli tank fired on your house
and your three daughters and a niece
were all killed in the most brutal
manner imaginable blown to Pieces by
this tank and you were there it was with
them and there was an extraordinary
moment and I have asked if if you're
comfortable with us to play little bit
of this because it I remembered at the
time I was at CNN uh we just about to
join CN I remember uh hearing this and
it was uh just so moving because you had
a friend in an Israeli television
station and you had regular dialogue
with him during this war and you would
call in and you'd update and so on and
you came on and you spoke to him just
after you'd lost your daughters to this
strike and this is a little bit of that
conversation
for
it's it's one of the most agonizing
things I've ever watched on television
and eventually your friend that
presenter he had to he had to go because
he wanted to keep talking to you and he
was so distressed himself he wanted to
go off and do it privately which he did
but an agonizing moment for you for him
for everybody involved in that and as a
consequence of that many people in your
position may have chosen a path of
wanting revenge or retribution in some
way to meet violence with violence but
you went completely a different way and
you ended up taking your family and you
ended up in
Canada how did you find the strength to
not go down the path of wanting Revenge
it's important what you mentioned
because my wife passed away 16th of
September 2008 qu to 5:00 p.m. and my
daughters were killed 16th of January
2009 quter to 5 p.m. 4 months
exactly
two traumas
tragedies and what you heard what I said
Ya Allah y you know the meaning oh god
oh Lord yes at that moment as what I see
now I lost faith in the
humanity because the world was watching
what is happening as we are watching
what is happening now Palestinians are
just numbers they are not numbers they
are human yes and that's what I would
like each of us who are watching to zoom
end to put himself in the position of
the Palestinians you know what you did
so powerfully uh doctor was when you
showed the pictures of your family so
but it's you but you put a name in the
to the face and you made people at home
watching this understand me but it's
important what helped me I am a person
of
Faith this is
important my life experience my
profession as a medical doctor if a
patient dies I don't stay
there I have to move to the next patient
to save but I need to learn why the
first patient died and what are the
causes the triggers of the death of that
patient let's just pause there I've got
to take a break when we come back I want
to talk about the root cause of all this
and I want to talk about how you believe
from this current nightmare not least
for you and your family we can somehow
maybe get to peace I think you're one of
the best people to talk to about that so
we'll back after the break with do Dr
Abu
[Music]
Le
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
well I'm still with Dr isalan abues I'm
sure anyone who watched that uh first
part of his interview uh would have been
like me I think
very I think taken aback by the
eloquence that you talk with the courage
that you speak with it's really palpable
and uh I'm just so glad you came in to
do this with me face to face so I can
really feel it from you because you're
so right Palestinian lives are as
important as Israeli
lives and you know here's the question I
want to ask
you how do we your entire life has been
ravaged by this conflict from when you
were a baby to now and you've lost so
many members of your family and you're
losing them as we speak probably
horrifically in this camp that you grew
up in it's like this Vicious Circle That
Never Ends how do we end it yeah we need
to end to understand the root causes of
the problem the Palestinian people and
the Israeli people and I described it we
are like conjoined it
twins we have no other way than to live
together and when we speak about peace
and the people they talk about peace
peace is not just a word peace is a way
of life that we believe in it and there
are between whom we want peace peace is
a relationship between me and you even
peace is a relationship between us and
the Earth that we damag the Earth with
the the clim to change and there are
certain requirements for peace we need
Justice equality freedom
human rights right equal rights human
equal rights then peace will be a
consequence of that can peace ever be
achieved now if Hamas are in charge in
Gaza as I mentioned to you it's about
Palestinian people and then Israeli
people it's not about Palestinians and
the settlers SM or B or those settlers
we want peace between the people and
that's what is needed Palestinians and
Israelis we are created but that has to
in the end that has to be a political
solu solution it's the only way do but
do you think on either side there is the
leadership there that can possibly Forge
peace believe me even if there is no we
need the International Community to
bring them and we have the platform we
have the international resolutions we
have the human rights resolutions
because ending the conflict all of the
world will benefit from it you see the
consequences of what is happening now
the consequences are spreading
everywhere in the world you see it in UK
polarization the marshes everything so
when we solve the conflict there all of
the world will benefit from why do you
think it's not being solved yet I mean I
look at Northern Ireland for example
which was three decades or more of
violence but eventually it got resolved
but it seems to you know why why I met
with Martin mcginness before and he said
to me we were going confronting each
other once we started to move side by
side as equal we put an end to that and
that's what we need the International
Community the world that we can
Palestinians and Israelis to move side
by side as equal with dignity and
respect of the human rights not as
Fighters because a small room can't
accommodate Two fighters but it can
accommodate hundreds of a friends and
that's the only way and we are so close
to each other the communalities between
Palestinians and Israel is more than
anyone else so we need to use it but
based as I said on equality respect of
the human rights Dignity of the
Palestinians is equal to the Dignity of
the Israelis the freedom of the
Palestinians even I go far beyond that
the Israelis Freedom safety security a
future and Independence is linked and
dependent on the
Palestinians we are one we are conjoined
twins we can't separate it so it's time
to understand also military means and
power will never put an end to this do
you do you obviously you dream of this
but do you think it's a realistic dream
that in your lifetime you can have a
two-state solution with Israel and
Palestine both identifying each other as
States and people living with equal
human rights do you think that's
possible as I said to you nothing is
impossible in life if there is a will
there is way and that's what is needed
and that's what is needed even if the
Palestinians and the Israelis there is a
challenge we need the involvement of the
International Community Based on Fair
intervention based on the inter because
we want to have order in this world we
want you know this order because you we
live in a discordant World these days so
we want to resume trust in the
International Community in order the
people in this world they lost safety
security trust so we want to resume it
and that's the only way to start with
the Palestinian Israeli conflict based
on the human rights conventions the
international resolutions and to resume
trust in the international institutions
believe me I see it yes it can be
quickly if I ask you before yat will
meet with Rabin and to shake hands one
year before 94 are you crazy they will
not yeah and they met they were calling
yes arat as a terrorist but then he
became a hero Nelson Mandela yes he was
a terrorist yeah but he was from his
side he was a freedom fighter and that's
what we need we need wisdom we need the
rational people we need the involvement
of the International Community doctor We
R out of time on this interview and I
know you want to go and find out what's
happening to your family right now I
would love to stay in touch with you I
would love you to come back on the show
regularly and we talk about this because
you're such a powerful voice thank you
for you so much my dear my heart goes
out to you for what's happened to your
family it really does for all the family
members you've lost than you for all of
the Palestinian and the Israelis yes you
are an amazing voice thank you thank you
very much indeed thank you a remarkable
man Dr Isel abues and says the next
tonight Israel will Implement 4-Hour
pauses to let civilians flee from Gaza
but calls for full-blown ceasefire grow
ever louder should Israel hold his
[Music]
fire
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
for today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
thei sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose I am
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and the national soci party
for the preservation of the habitat of
the Lesser spotted M the problem lies in
the bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solve
you go who's fit as a butcher do him all
right but but he's now middle class us
here t I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me
up this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back the G7 including the UK
and us is calling for humanitarian
pauses in Gaza many other countries in
the Middle East are demanding a full
ceasefire Israel has ruled out to ceas
fire while Hamas holds around 240
hostages who are kidnapped during a
deadly Terror attacks on October the 7th
it says there's already tactical pauses
in its daily assaults on the Gaza Strip
well more than 10 and a half thousand
people reported now been killed in Gaza
including over 4,000 children according
to the Hamas run Health Ministry on
Sunday the pope made an urgent ple to
stop the conflict saying I pray to you
to stop in the name of God cease the
fire so with so much Bloodshed is it
time for Ace fire join me how to discuss
this America's Rabbi and bestselling
author rabbi schmy bayak and welcome
back to Young Turks Creator and
Democratic presidential Challenger Jen
yugar well welcome to both of you um Jen
let me start with you many people are
calling for a ceasefire Queen Ria of
Jordan Angelina Jolie uh Arab leaders
and so on uh I presume you would agree
with
that yeah absolutely uh I think that
they've murdered enough Palestinian
civilians uh and even Netanyahu in an
interview with ABC news said now that
we're were on the ground were finally
pressuring Hamas on hostages oh so the
7,000 bombs you dropped were totally
useless and Collective punishment and
your attempt to murder civilians on
purpose as some sort of sick Vengeance
so please stop the murders ceasefire
right now Rabbi SMY your
response uh Chen is polling in the
Democratic presidential primaries at 0%
nothing he has a greater likelihood of
being elected the new king of France and
no don't interrupt me please and the
reason is that the American people are
decent they understand that Chen's
anti-Semitism which he has voiced on
your show repeatedly calling Jews
genocide dares and this is the eve of
Christal the 85th Anniversary of the
start of the Holocaust he would deny the
Jewish people the only dignity left to
us that we were victims of genocide and
he would say that we are the Nazis we
are the gapa for simply wanting to
defend ourselves against the brutality
and the Savage
of Hamas shank shank shank shank shank
you'll have your turn just show some
decency if you're not going to show it
to my people show it to me and show it
to the viewers of the show stop but who
is surprised that a man who is surprised
that a man who whose name the name of
whose podcast is Young Turks who
perpetrated The Armenian Genocide The
Young Turks is like calling your podcast
the young Nazis the youngest APO they
killed one and a half to two million
Armenians between 1915 and 1918 The
Armenian Community has begged shank to
change the name of his show for the
first half of his life he was a complete
Armenian genoci he
changed now now now he is a holocaust
denier because he is saying that the
Jews are engaged in a genocide of the
Palestinian which nation How can there
be 1.8 million Muslim Arab citizens me
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to J you said
you said some very strong things about
Jen you can now respond Jen
yeah this you should never have the sky
on air everything he said is a lie I
don't deny the Holocaust that's insanity
and in terms of the Armenian Genocide uh
there is a powerful analogy there why
was it a genocide and yes it was a
genocide why because they moved and
displaced so many people and killed
civilians on the way what is Israel
doing moving and displacing millions of
people and killing innocent civilians it
is the exact definition of a genocide so
I don't I I think the Jewish people are
an amazing people and their their
culture is beautiful and I don't
tolerate any anti-Semitism but I think
that the occupation is decaying the
moral core of Israel how long are you
going to oppress these people and I know
this guy all he wants to do is an ad
homm attack he's a liar he's and you
could tell exactly what kind of indecent
human being he is but the main reason
he's doing it is to avoid the topic when
when are you going to stop murdering
Palestinians and cheerleading it if
you're talking about genocide you're the
one right now doing the genocide may I
respond may I respond go morees go ahead
you know I've spent I've spent my life
debating people whenever someone
whenever someone starts using personal
names and screaming like a lunatic
they're losing the debate let me Remain
the Palestinian the Palestinians the
Palestinians the the Palestinians were
offered a state in 1936 in the appeal
commission they rejected it they were
offered to state in 1947 the UN
partition plan they rejected it they
were offered to state in 1967 after
Israel conquered judan Samaran in the
West Bank they rejected it they were
offered a state in 2000 yaser arat a
Barack they rejected it they were
offered a state with aod Omar 2008 they
rejected it they have Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza in 2005
and they did not create a state in fact
where were you chank when you say that
you care about Palestinian children when
Hamas stole the highest rate of per
capita International foreign aid larger
than the Marshall Plan from Palestinian
children did not build schools for them
did not build hospitals took all the
money to buy bombs and to build a
network of tunnels which is larger than
the than the New York Subway system
where were you then why did you only
come up now in fact when Bashar al-assad
killed
600,000 children Arab children when he
gassed them with mustard gas my
organization took out full page New York
Times ads to protect them from sarin gas
where were you then you don't care about
Arab children you are a Jew hater
defined as someone who only wants to lie
and say that the Jews are genocide and
don't try to cancel me and say that I
shouldn't be on you're not a producer of
this show because you are ignorant of
the facts and ignorant of the history
does not mean that you can cancel my
voice your
response okay so first of all
you this guy is a full-blown bigot he's
one of the most racist people I have
ever seen does not value Palestinian
lives at all all and everything he said
about me is 100% untrue I was vicious in
my criticism of Bashar al-assad I've
have criticized Hamas over and over
again and I think what they did in the
attack against Israel was reprehensible
but for God's sake how long are you
going to occupy these people for me the
idea of Israelis and Palestinians or
Muslims or Jews being different is
absurd those are just stupid labels that
we put on people they're all human
beings I value the Israeli life just as
much as I value the Palestinian life
we're all human stop using these Naz lab
me ask kill each other all this guy
wants to do is more murder of
Palestinians let me ask when are you
going to let them go Jen let me ask you
a question you mentioned genocide there
what Hamas is actually in its Charter
dedicated to doing is the purest
personification of genocide well it is
they want to see the eradication of
Israel and they proved on October the
7th they will kill as many Jews as they
can possibly get their hands on so that
is pure genocide what Israel is doing in
return I don't think meets the category
of genocide right because they don't
want to get rid of every Palestinian
they don't want to kill every
Palestinian no they want to kill every
Hamas terrorist now there are legitimate
question marks about how they're going
about this and about the civilian
casualties but there is a there is a a
moral distinction between what Hamas is
dedicated to doing and what is is
dedicated to doing isn't
that no uh first of all Hamas is a bunch
of idiots they should take that stuff
out of their Charter it all it does is
hurt the Palestinian cause there's no
call for it it's dumb and it's immoral
but Hamas claims that they would like to
do these things and from time to time
they do these attacks that are horrible
and they should never do but Israel
actually kills Palestinians actually
occupies Palestine actually denies the
Palestinians estate so there's this AB
ABD talk of like oh if Hamas was superp
powerful they might deny Israel its
existence except Israel does exist and
and in the Palestinian state does not
exist because Israel is blocking their
state so stop using Pro and I'm not
say hold
on and I you and I you and I J you and I
you and I are almost the same age and
I'm actually quite worried for how upset
you get on TV you got to protect your
health you're just kind of losing it now
calm down I'm upset keep adva saying you
have to stop yelling you have to stop
screaming and you need to know the facts
the Palestinians were offered a state
seven times and they rejected it seven
times Bill Clinton told yasar arat in
2000 you have made me a failure as
president because Israel was giving you
97% of Judea and Samaria and the old
city of Jerusalem and AUD Barack even
offered the Temple mount the holy asight
ined Judaism and the Palestinians
rejected it you simply don't know the
history read a book in fact read a
Wikipedia article before you get on TV
number two you know you made a very good
point before Pierce that Winston
Churchill is the greatest British
Statesman and hero of the 20th century
let's remember when Churchill was faced
with a genocidal threat of the Nazis you
know what he did which is what we never
consider doing he laid waste to 70% of
Dresden Essen cologne Berlin he just he
eviscerated Germany and turned it into a
parking lot murdering about 6 million
German civilians Israel has never even
considered doing a thousandth of that
and FDR acquiesced to it and he's
considered our greatest president of the
20th century and then Harry Truman
dropped two atomic bombs on Nagasaki
Hiroshima so I and Israel has nuclear
weapons has never considered doing that
Israel opened
aan beg no so I have so I have
one simple question Jen I want to ask
you a question call Winston Churchill a
war criminal on this show today will you
call us Churchill a war criminal all
right Jen answer that question okay so
Rabbi schi if you're actually a rabbi um
what the standards of history have
changed so the Mongols went into Baghdad
and killed every man woman and child
killed 800,000 people the largest city
in the world now we don't live by those
standards anymore and right now if a a
modern British prime minister or
American president uh advocated for
dropping a nuclear bomb in Japan or
killing 70% of the people that live in
drenon you're damn right I'd call him a
war criminal it's a different situation
today than it was in the past and so
what you're saying is hey we only
murdered 10,000 civilians unwantedly and
recklessly and we only did a partial
genocide so we're not as guilty not I
I'm not buying it at
all I ask you question hang on RAB I
want to ask you a question which is this
which is the unique scenario in Gaza is
that nearly half of the civilian
population are children they have
nothing to do with this they're not
politicians they're not in Hamas they're
not terrorists they're not military
they're kids and they are in their
thousands being killed here and I ask
you really is there is there any limit
you as a rabbi of the number of children
who need to be killed to get rid of
Hamas here or is there no
limit of course there's a limit we mourn
the death of every Arab Muslim
Palestinian child as if a Jewish child
died they are absolutely equal before
God that's why Israel withdrew
completely and utterly in 2005 something
that Jen will not even acknowledge there
isn't one Israeli soldier there wasn't
until this new Invasion because of the
attack on deot because of I went to
those places Pierce I was there two
weeks ago I saw the blood caked on the
walls congealed to three or 4 inches I
saw the knives that were used to murder
entire families we saw the place where
taii not Jewish Thai Farm Workers who
were growing pumpkins were beheaded we
saw the body of of Shaunie Luke and I
spoke to her mother Ricarda who was
taken naked these are religious men in
Kamas taken naked in her underwear and
her bra her dead body these necrofilia
Savages we saw all that how many how
many Palestinian children need to die
God forbid not one all Hamas needs to do
is let the civilian population go south
stop using them as human Shields Hamas
wants these Palestinian children to die
every Palestinian child to Hamas is a
bulletproof you said you for no other
reason than to humiliate Israel let them
go south and be safe but Hamas wants
them it's hamas's fault it's hamas's
fault it's hamas's fault raabi you did
say there is a limit what is that
limit uh Pierce it's hard to put a
number on how many people Kamas is
prepared to allow to die in order to
destroy the state of Israel remember
hamas's motto is from the sea from the
from the from C to see Israel will be uh
Palestine will be free it's the
annihilation of every Jew Iran calls for
it openly a second Holocaust this is the
eve of Christal I don't want to put a
number on how many Palestinian children
we I want to cease fire right now now
Kamas must surrender unconditionally
just like FDR and just like Churchill
demanded of the Nazis unconditional
surrender release the hostages we get a
ceasefire right now Chen let me ask you
to call for a ceasefire by having Hamas
who you think actually cares about the
Palestinian
population announce their surrender call
for their surrender right now they
launched this attack unprovoked against
Israel they slaughtered 1400 people they
are holding little babies whose diapers
need to be changed as hostages call for
them to surrender
unconditionally can we okay so look all
this is nonsense uh first of all Israel
did not withdraw they controlled the
borders of Gaza 100% And as you can tell
now they cut off the water and power
anytime they want uh the Jewish people
have been oppressed throughout history
my heart goes out to the Jewish people
for all the pain and the suffering that
they have endured through all of these
years but now Israel unfortunately is
not the oppressed it is the oppressor
look at them dropping 7,000 bombs on
grandmothers and children there's an
American nurse that explained on CNN
yesterday about how she sees uh little
kids with Burns all across their bodies
so Hamas is terrible yes I can call for
their surrender that's easy I don't like
Hamas I think Hamas is Muslim
fundamentalist but it's an impossible
standard and you know they're not going
to meet that standard and because you
want to keep killing those civilians to
show them how Mighty you are and what a
great oppressor you are I'm sick of it
and it's not only ruining the
Palestinians cusing their death R it is
calling it is cusing of Israel blood
liable blood liable this is a blood
liable against the Jewish people you may
as well just say that we drink the blood
Christian children and our you are
guilty of a blood Lial on the eve of
Crystal you should be ashamed of I'm I'm
going to a blood CH the name of your
show away from Young Turks who are
genocide who
mil back to the host here and call a
ceasefire for now it's been a
fascinating debate very passionate on
both sides I get that I appreciate you
both agreeing to debate each other I
think that's important in this uh
situation and thank you for coming on
the show thank you yeah I appreciate it
uh this this guy's ruining that there's
tremendous anti-Semitism in the world by
crying wolf he's
actuallya from people like okay you're a
bigot stop killing Palestinians you
bigot
okay we're going to leave it there thank
you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
he
coming up at 9:00 the independent
republic is going to be asking an awful
lot of questions like why do people feel
it necessary not to wear a poppy these
days why is it so difficult to find
people selling poppies on the streets of
this country and why do so many people
coming up for the armor this weekend
fear that the London capital city is not
safe not for them not this weekend it's
all coming
[Music]
up welcome back to uncensored Hamas
terrorists are still holding around 240
hostages who they kidnapped and brought
into Gaza during the October 7th Terror
attacks posters displaying their faces
clearly many of the children A desperate
plea for he have been put up on walls
around the globe however anti-israel
protesters have taken it upon themselves
to rip them down in New York multiple
Flyers are torn away daily in Germany
police were caught tearing down posters
of hostages too and here in London the
same has happened my next guest was C in
the ACT sheab El Rafi REI tore down
posters of the hostages in Los Angeles
and he joins me now uh Mr refi why would
you rip down posters of hostages why
would you that what's the answer because
it is perpetuating a completely false
narrative that the Israelis are the
victims of which I do not promote uh any
violence towards any innocent human
being regardless of their background or
beliefs or any uh type of targeting of a
specific individual and those people
that have their pictures on those
posters I do not know them and I do not
wish anybody who is innocent any type of
harm it is more of a symbolic gesture
because it is pathetic propaganda that
they are putting in into uh civilian
areas that we are living in and they're
perpetuating this narrative to keep
subconsciously people to think that
Hamas are terrorists let me tell you
what they let me not even refer to Hamas
just the Palestinian people in general
and Muslim people in general yeah let me
tell you the 911 let me tell you the
context of of where you did this you
were several blocks down from the
Holocaust Museum in Los Angeles there
are many Jewish people who live in Los
Angeles and these 240 hostages include
grandmothers who escaped the Holocaust
they include three-month-old babies they
include many children and their families
are understanded be desperate for
information about where they are and
whether they're still alive and we've
already had some cases where people from
the identity on the posters they have
been identified as still alive why would
you deprive families of
that all due respect to anybody who is
suffering uh the loss of people that
they love which many people around the
world are currently suffering from but
there's always a spotlight on a specific
demographic of people because apparently
just like George O would say some people
are more equal than others and also a
very important clarification that needs
to be done is the difference between
Zionism and Judaism Zionism is a
political ideology that is using Judaism
as a front to push its agenda whereas
Judaism is simply a religion of which my
own Rel
question we're talking about 240 people
why are you laughing what's possibly
funny about this because it's because
it's because if you have uh the
background information that I have about
the world in general and how politics is
a game and war is business you'd realize
why this I'm not laughing at people
suffering not at all I completely you
literally were laughing you were
literally laughing as I asked you about
2 hostages including a three-month old
baby uh what about all the people that
are getting obliterated in Gaz now why
stop why don't you stop playing what
about there are mass protest happened to
theost to be clear hold on what happened
to the old lady that was released and
she shook his hand before there are mass
protest apprciate if you don't interrupt
me there are mass protests all over the
world Pro Palestinian protests they I
haven't joined a
single all a single
protest but they're being allowed to
happen I would like I would like to send
a message to those protesters and
protesters around the world
when you go out into the street uh
begging your so-called leaders to do
something why don't you do something
yourself why are we why do we keep
giving the authority and power to
certain pathetic individuals who have no
competence to be in the positions that
they're in to continue having the quote
unquote power the power is within each
and every single individual which is
something we have completely forgotten
and this is how they they have people
like puppets on strings again I simply
ask
you many Meers
I simply ask you why you would rip down
posters of people who've been taken
hostage which may give their families
some hope if someone can identify them
that they may still be alive just like
okay let me answer your question on
multiple layers it's false hope number
one if they really wanted them back
they'd be back number two uh what about
all the other families that are
suffering from they're seeing their
direct family getting bombed and their
entire um
the videos that I'm seeing on accounts
like M's Instagram page and many other
journalists that are there posting about
these things if I started doing that on
the street and putting his content just
take a screenshot and put it on the
Street Los Angeles and any place that is
of a civilian manner is not going to be
civilian anymore it's going to be too
graphic for people to walk around on the
streets and live their Day live the rest
of their lives and also another message
to nothing to do with the question I
asked you
again nothing to do with it you're not
answering the question understanding the
nuances of my communication you know
what I've got to be honest with you uh I
don't really care about your subtle
nuances or you thinking it's all
entertaining because it's a
multi-layered it's a multilayer it's not
multi-layered you are walking around
near the Holocaust Museum in Los Angeles
a place I've attended several times and
found profoundly moving and you're
walking around you walking around there
several weeks after the worst attack on
Jewish people since the Holocaust it's
not on Jewish people 240
inal and your only contribution to this
is to walk around and rip down hostage
posters and you seem to find it funny my
main contribution would be to educate
people on what is really happening well
let me educate you beat
toed what you are doing is shockingly
insensitive and inappropriate and
hurtful to the family members of those
people taken hostage including many
young children children and by the way I
also think the deaths of all the
children in Gaza is horrific and I've
said so many times but what you are
doing I respect your
your standard your sole contribution to
this is to rip down posters of hostages
and I find that contempt we'll end the
interview there thank you for your time
that's it for me whatever you're up to
make sure it's un sensive good
[Music]
night
[Applause]
[Music]